hi everybody this is Jessica Chobot
and on this episode of player vs. gamer
we are hanging out in Hollywood
California with Golden State Warriors
Harrison Barnes to see just how much of
a gamer he really is and if his skills
on the basketball court can translate to
the virtual hardwood as he takes on LA
point guard Kendall Marshall in NBA 2k14
this is the only show where gaming and
sports come head-to-head GameSpot
presents player versus gamer meet our
players Harrison Barnes is a small
forward with Golden State Warriors he
attended the University of North
Carolina where he was one of the
top-rated basketball players in the
recruiting class of 2010 sometimes known
by the nickname Black Falcon the NBA
named Barnes - the 2012-2013 all-rookie
first team now before Harrison takes on
NBA 2k14 on Microsoft's Xbox one I
thought I'd find out a little bit more
about the Warriors player and get a free
basketball lesson in the process so
what's it like playing for the word for
the Warriors is great yeah I mean we
have we played an exciting style you
know we have you know I first came to
the team not a lot of people knew about
Stefan curry and now he'd you know top
five top ten plan to leave right now
I mean it was such guys that are you
know humble and fun to be around now if
you're playing a two-on-two game who
would you choose any video game
character out there who would you choose
to team up with not just basketball team
anybody probably link from super smash
brothers and their novices over why
specifically link who is that's why one
of my favorite he's just one of my you
know favorite characters obviously
growing up to the smash wasn't one of my
favorite games so he was the character
I'd always go to maybe they were
thinking of VidCon - fantastic I'm very
happy that that's when you chose it puts
a smile on my face he's a good character
are there any tips for how to hold the
basketball or is it kind of just you
just hold a basketball right hand on the
ball uh-huh the top left on the side
okay and she liked that she liked that
so now that we got a peek of Harrison
skills on the basketball court it's time
to take over for the ultimate showdown
on Microsoft's Xbox one of course the
game of choice NBA 2k14 the latest
installment in the NBA's number one
video game franchise 2k 14 delivers an
unprecedented level of realism
incredible visuals that add to your
emotional investment action flows just
like the real game and ramps up
defensive intensity forces you to
smartly plan your offense before
Harrison drives the lane on the virtual
court it's time to check in with Chris
waters for more information on NBA 2k14
hey there Jessica these days NBA 2k14 is
the reigning champion of video game
basketball one look at the game in
action and you'll see what I mean
because it looks incredible the level of
detail in the players is astounding from
the looks on their faces to the way they
play the animations are so realistic
that whenever I see a co-worker playing
the game it actually takes me a second
to realize it's actually the game and
not a live broadcast of the NBA and it's
not just looks the ebb and flow of each
game the way players adapt is the action
unfolds it all leads to the heightened
sense that you are part of the game
the dramatic victories the crushing
defeat virtual basketball has never been
as exciting as it is in NBA 2k14 for the
Xbox one starting off as a rookie
working your way up through the league
making a name for yourself and taking a
shot at the championship it's an
absolute blast but that's not what's in
store for you guys I have a feeling this
contest is gonna be one of the most
heated yet
good luck Jessica thanks Chris now
before we have tip-off I wanted to sit
down with Harrison and get a little bit
more information about your video game
prowess
so yeah video games what do you play I
put a lot of different games from
obviously you know NBA 2k to you know
call of duty
sass ins Creed Borderlands 2 so I try to
try to mix it up a little bit what is
your earliest memory of video
like what system was the first system
you ever had how do Sega Genesis
Oh your Genesis not Nintendo Nintendo
usually the default I'm very impressed
I'm the rather say Genesis a long long
time ago thinking back to it it was
terrible quality but you know at the
time it was I loved having a video game
are you really big into the NBA 2k
franchise at all is it like a kind of a
staple that you play it's always a
staple then I play I mean it's began
that I'll know more than any of the rest
of them no matter how much I haven't
played and you know it's something that
I think you know most baffle players
play well so I was going to say does it
make it obviously your background being
a basketball player does it make it
easier to pick up when you play a game
like that or do you notice kind of the
things that are slightly off about kind
of lost in translation from real life to
like the video game world actually it's
it's come a long way I know when I very
first started playing I noticed there
was like you know huge US government
sees you know all stars you know could
just you know similar stuff from the
free-throw line and you always got the
foul always made their shots and now
they've changed though so much you know
what the graphics and you know how it
you know the controls feel the graphics
I'm really glad you brought that up
because the graphics are so on point and
they get better and better with new
iteration of system that comes out so is
it weird seeing people you know on
screen and they look so realistic is
that do you have that kind of uncanny
valley situation happen to you you're
like whoops makes me awkward yeah it
honestly it never gets old I mean just
any time you're playing especially on
your next-gen comparing it to you know
the old version I mean it's it's like
daylight in darkness I mean just seeing
how you know real guys look you know how
you know from team to team I mean
there's there's no there's no
discrepancy I mean it's it's crazy now
who's your default team that you always
go to play in something like NBA 2k
before they blew the team up it was the
Bulls so all the players healthy I was
pretty much an estoppel with them but
you know
injuries happened in fact the end of the
game trade so I'm on the search for a
new team how do you choose how do you
decide who you want to pick it has to be
you know just a well-balanced team I
mean obviously defog I can go with the
Warriors but
it's kind of weird you know planted you
know the team you always play on ya know
so I try just mix it up you know right
now like the pace is a lot you know
balanced team now you specifically chose
Kendall to go up against why did you
choose that well Kendall was my roommate
obviously I know to Carolina and we've
been playing video games ever since you
know I went to college whether it was
you know super smash brothers melee I
was you know newest to ki whether it was
you know Matt and whatever it was I mean
we've always played video games stay
tuned for more player vs. gamer after
this break
part it's time to meet our gamer none
other than LA Lakers Kendall Marshall
thanks for having me
so you guys you and Harrison actually go
way way back tell me a little bit about
how you first met oh well we first met I
think was in a basketball camp when we
were in high school probably going into
our junior year and ended up we ended up
going to the same College what is your
experience as far as being a video gamer
hence the fact that you are a gamer I
assume that you have quite a repertoire
of video games um you know I really
didn't get big into video games until
college really you know I played a
little bit in a in high school and
elementary with my uncle's came over but
mostly as I was around my teammates in
college okay and so did you guys ever
play against each other or will this be
the first time this might be the first
time I don't know we sometimes we're on
the same team when we play like Call of
Duty and stuff but uh you know I stayed
away from the 2k battles oh you did why
I would think that that would be
something you would gravitate to that
was a big Mortal Kombat ok growing up oh
okay so fighting games armor yeah it's
just Mortal Kombat I'm Tom B's come on
oh yeah as always
okay so your prefer to go with like
waves of enemies not necessarily like
online multiplayer all right well so
then knowing that you have shied away
from the 2k series how do you think
you're gonna do up against Harrison
today oh no I might be a little rusty
but you know we'll see what happens so
you Harrison have actually hand-picked
Kendal's specifically for this so what
makes him the perfect opponent for you
are just contrasting styles I know that
you know when we go and play 2k I know
Kendall's gonna play you know a very you
know team oriented game
you can get guys in fall you know make
the extra pass you know me I just I get
it to my star players and they gotta go
give me a bucket so do you have any
strategy going into this game uh a
little bit you know you know I've been
thinking a lot about what team I want to
use you know a team with a lot of
shooters mm-hmm highlight what I do well
and uh get guys involved so I think I
think I can get it done today
all right guys this is how it's gonna go
down we're gonna do traditional
five-on-five six minute quarters team of
your choice and here's a quick look at
the player versus gamer scoreboard the
gamers lead the series against our
players to to wine neck you ready ready
ready
still you smiling okay good let's go
feeling good about 2k today do anything
- no no no I feel like oh no we got a
their religious shot see what happens
hey can we ride with Denver yeah let me
see I think I'm gonna go with Pacers
like George George Hill lock that up
we are live in Denver Colorado a
hometown for the Nuggets for an Eastern
versus Western Conference matchup right
here
go top early for three yell no good oh
boy is on the way Junko gonna be over
early man and its really penetrating Oh
bad blocks good Boris : patience real
cow oh oh that was left
okay see you lots of nice in this game
here is Watson Watson defending
and so Joe Strummer not busy this is
that one it's kinda gonna suck man
just kidding de Robinson in there you
know who makes on that Harrison Barnes
got off to a slow start at the beginning
of the first quarter but he rallied back
to keep the game close at 17 to 18 looks
like it's gonna be a good game
pop
now here is Robinson George Hill missing
his last shot
Oh oh wow
go with me that's the spark often we
needed a minute 20 left in the first
half one shot that's the way you finish
out ahead it's halftime and while
Harrison kept the fight strong Kendall
managed to stay ahead and start the
second half up seven points let's see if
Harrison can turn the tables killing you
on the boards we came a rebound I mean
that was ridiculous Hey get that out of
here the Pacers have missed a few free
throws up to this point shooting 4 of 7
from the foul line tonight
gosh we'd have no turbo we'll hit a 3 no
foul one
take a charge oh yes sir good take tie
yours robinson's it's stolen by Watson
five seconds I'm with oh thank goodness
I did not get blog now Robinson oh my
god oh my god come on man bottles and
mist baskets leave Kendall's Nuggets
with a comfortable lead can Harrison
pull it together for the upset well as
we head to the court all I gotta do is
take care of the ball
Oh wrong person
are you kidding me good Sabbath Lynch
good shot
Watson the pastor school
come on give me one listen he ain't
gonna make all these ain't gonna make
all these now rebound and to read kicks
de for put them threes down there to
people there are you serious let's go in
one all my I've made the second one oh
you supposed to pad just a tomato
what oh my it wasn't
and that's game time another half
congratulations to our gamer a round of
applause for Kendall everybody
appreciate it oh my pleasure at Harrison
I'm sorry but I thought you better
turned around there in the third and
fourth quarter so what happened I was
hurt you know starting point guard did
give me anything I can get into there
I'm sorry never a good game guys good
game all around congratulations alright
folks at home looks like our gamers are
still in the lead but who's gonna take
it next time find out on the next player
versus gamer